and now to present the award for the
best actress the rough tough Idol of a
million feminine hearts to gun
two-fisted mr. John Wayne right here
Thank You Bobby
what do you think you put it on a little
thick well actually John I wrote that
interaction for myself but the place is
crawling with integrity where'd you been
lately Long John making a big - in Japan
isn't that a little far west for a
Western oh we had no choice they've used
all the Indians they're all under hired
a television here what's the plot -
rustlers hijacking a stagecoach full of
wonton soup Duke let's get back to the
plot here huh the nominations for the
Best Performance by an actress our
Deborah Carr and heaven knows mr.
Allison Hahnemann yani and wild is the
wind Elizabeth Taylor and Raintree
County Lana Turner Peyton Place and
Joanne Woodward in three faces of Eve
the winner is Joanne Woodward
I can only say that I've been
daydreaming about this since I was nine
years old thank you very much thanks
most of all bundling for having more
faith in me than I think anybody could